there's a new poll out this morning that
shows that labor is only four points
ahead of the conservatives in terms of
the public's voting intentions
why is that margin so close when the
conservatives are tearing lumps out of
each other in this leadership contest
well there'll be lots of different polls
that we can look at and of course
they've been going up and down let's not
forget that labour's had a 14-point lead
as well but what we've got actually
essentially is we've got two
conservative councillors as you say
taking lumps out of each other all the
while the state that we find the country
and is really as a result of uh their
decision-making in the last sort of
government that we've heard but we've
had the conservatives in power for 12
years i mean this week alone we saw that
the government is saying that it's going
to miss its own targets in terms of the
nhs waiting list we now have 6.6 million
people on the waiting list for planned
care i mean on that is the largest
number on record and you know the the
other thing as you say you know a basic
government functions are clearly not
working we've had the delays in terms of
uh lorry drivers i've had numerous
constituents contact me
as i'm sure mps across the country have
around uh delays in passport tens of
thousands of people are waiting over ten
weeks and we've also seen the court
backlog rise from 43
in the last five years and so yes of
course the conservatives have created
backlog britain and both of the
leadership candidates rishi and sunni
they're not talking about these issues
that are taking place they haven't got a
plan as to how they are going to
address this which is making life very
very difficult for lots of people um
and of course what the country needs is
labor i mean labor is the fresh thought
that britain deserves
well but but what i'm saying is that the
polls don't suggest that people back you
on that if the country really is in such
bad shape if it really is backlogged
britain and in the meantime we've got
this ferocious leadership race why isn't
labour romping ahead in every poll
well i think we are look there'll be
consistent polls weren't there and of
course when you have a leadership
election there'll be a bounce no doubt
for whoever wins for a short period of
time but let's not forget the country
hasn't forgotten i mean at the moment in
time nothing seems to be working and you
know there is crisis upon crisis and all
the while you know you've got two
candidates that are too bothered about
you know uh sort of appealing to their
sort of members as opposed to addressing
the cost of living crisis labor has put
forward lots of credible things actually
that could be done immediately to sort
of get uh inflation steady um cutting
bat for example the government just
hasn't got a plan i think it's just
unacceptable the leadership that's being
provided is actually being provided by
the labour party
well rishi sunak has promised to to cut
vat on energy bills and you talk about
the economy the bank of england is uh
expected to raise interest rates today
possibly by as much as half of one
percent so tell us what labour would do
to help vulnerable families
for whom that that could be a further
squeeze
well you can't just have tax cuts and
not have a plan for growth i mean we we
know that either that will mean that
you'll have public finances firing out
of control or you're going to have to
make cuts to public spending and neither
of those two options are something that
we can afford in this country
but as you say rising inflation is
really hitting so many families uh you
know very very hard but the low wage
spiral that we've actually seen is not
something new it's actually the result
of 12 years of the tory mismanagement of
our economy where living standards all
real wages have failed to absolutely
grow so taking bat off energy bills
would absolutely push inflation down
well this is something that labour has
been calling for and the government
could do that immediately it was steady
inflation as you say it will actually
put more money in people's pockets um
the very fact that we have low tax and
high growth uh economy is rather than
raising taxes rather than wasting
billions of pounds of taxpayers money as
this government has been doing they
should have been taking steps to boost
the economy and to grow the economy and
absolutely labor has a very credible
option in terms of making sure we have
an active industrial strategy with a
skill strategy that we focus on growing
those industries so we can create those
jobs of the future um
that is what it would require to grow
the economy
um we've just got a little bit of
breaking news actually that's just come
into us and offgem the energy regulator
has just confirmed that the energy price
cap is going to be confirmed it's going
to be updated quarterly rather than
every six months as happens at the
moment um it's warned that customers
face a very challenging winter ahead uh
something that we are of course aware of
so your response to that is it a good
move that offgem updates the price cap
every quarter rather than every six
months
i mean it's it's basically we know that
the prices are going to rise
significantly and they're going to
continue to go up so actually reporting
by two months is actually giving the
government uh you know a heads up to say
what is it that you are doing to
supporting people what what the
government shouldn't be doing is giving
tax breaks to oil and gas companies made
huge amounts of profits of four billion
pounds what labour is calling for is
that the government needs to be
supporting those families that are going
to be hit this winter those families are
really really struggling that many could
absolutely um support them in supporting
their families the government hasn't
just been able to come up with a
credible offer
i want to get your view on the situation
in taiwan you are shadow cabinet
minister for um
international development do you welcome
nancy pelosi's visit to taiwan
look i mean nancy pelosi's decision to
go and visit was a decision of hers and
of course she said this is about
solidarity and we've seen the response
from china being quite significant i
think we all want to see some dialogue
really want to see peaceful moves to
address the issues um across the
taiwan straits we've been very clear
about our serious concerns with china's
sort of increasingly aggressive action
uh towards taiwan and the attempts to
intimidate its democratic leaders but i
think the actions are really part of a
wider
pattern of china becoming much much more
assertive but the issue we have is that
we've got a government that's very
divided on how to actually approach
china it's got no clear strategy um and
you know both liz and rishi have
actually um had a record of chronic
inconsistency i would say around china
so we've got to absolutely be clear
we've got to be working with china we
know that it's important in terms of
trade um but you know we've got to also
uh support taiwan because you know on
issues of global health it is absolutely
right it has a seat on the table in
terms of the w health show uh and other
institutions
well how worried are you about the
fallout from nancy pelosi's visit and
and what china might do next and you
talk about supporting taiwan what form
should that take as far as labour is
concerned
well what labour has um you know what we
have said is that we will take a
strategic approach to china china in
terms of standing firm on our principles
and interests and managing the
differences that we have china we
recognize that of course we've got to do
trade with china we've got to work on
the big issues of climate of global
health uh we just can't you know do it
alone without their support so i think
that's important um in in terms of how
worried i am i think look let's wait and
see i mean you know it's his early days
i think the chinese also want to uh
reach out and and hopefully engage in
some form of talks i think that this can
be the opportunity to start to see if
that is very possible but let's wait and
see